The SCP Foundation contains a lot of monsters.
From SCP-682, the lizard that refuses to die,
to SCP-939, a species of pack hunters that
steal the voices of their victims – the
dangerous predators that occupy the hundreds
of containment cells of the Foundation make
it their job to hunt and kill innocent people
– or worse.
But have you ever wondered where some of those
monsters come from?
The first encounter that the SCP Foundation
had with SCP-4049 was on July 14th of 2010.
The Foundation operates a massive surveillance
network around the entire world – through
the use of AI, delegated duties, and compartmentalized
information, they’re able to have 911 operators
report any calls that seem anomalous in nature
while knowing nothing about the Foundation
itself.
This way, they’re able to constantly be
aware of anything anomalous going on in the
country that gets reported to 911.
On July 14th, the Foundation was alerted of
a call that likely had an anomalous component.
At first, it didn’t seem like much.
It was to a remote address in Wyoming, outside
of a small town called Gardnerville.
The vacation home of one Richard Samson, a
wealthy businessman in the area, placed right
on the slopes.
The call was made late in the afternoon, by
someone purporting to be the groundskeeper
of the home while Mr. Samson was away.
He was screaming into the phone, terrified
and largely incoherent, but the operator made
out something about a monster attacking the
house.
There was a lot of noise in the background,
sounds of shouting, destruction, and what
sounded like animalistic roars and grunts.
The 911 operator moved the call up, and it
didn’t take long for the Foundation to determine
that something strange was going on here.
They dispatched a handful of agents, deep
undercover as officers with the Wyoming Highway
Patrol, to the address of the home where the
call had come from.
After about half an hour, the agents called
back in to HQ - the scene they had found was
nothing short of gruesome.
Upon arrival, they were greeted with what
appeared to be the aftermath of a particularly
violent and brief tornado.
The entire front section of the ground floor
had been shredded, the gardens trampled, and
the interior utterly destroyed.
The agents picked their way between the wreckage
of the home – it functionally didn’t exist
anymore.
The walls were collapsed from being rammed
and torn through, and the roof had collapsed
in on itself.
The broken shards and pieces of furniture
and wreckage were everywhere.
Despite appearances, this wasn’t a tornado
– a tornado would have thrown the entire
house around.
No, this was as the groundskeeper had said
– something alive, monstrous, and very angry.
Speaking of the groundskeeper, the Foundation
agents began to look for him once they took
stock of the damage to the home.
At first, they couldn’t find him among the
massive pieces of debris and assumed the worst.
Even if whatever had destroyed the house decided
to not kill him, he could easily have been
killed by the collapsing house, buried under
rubble, or a dozen other things.
They picked through the ruins, calling out
that they were from the police and were here
to help.
Eventually, after another half hour of searching,
they heard something.
What sounded like crying and whispering became
audible as the wind died down.
The agents honed in on the noise and found
it was coming from one of the larger piles
of rubble.
After getting some equipment, they were able
to heft up the piece of the collapsed roof,
and found the groundskeeper underneath, curled
into a ball and talking to himself.
He seemed to be in some kind of a panicked
fugue state, not responding to the agents
trying to get through to him.
They wrapped him in a shock blanket and put
him in the back of one of their patrol cars,
but even after that they couldn’t get anything
of use out of him - he was just shaking and
muttering something about monsters.
Eventually, he was given amnestics to forget
about the incident entirely and recovered.
After the agents reported back to HQ, a new
issue popped up - they weren’t the only
ones who knew about this.
A news website a few counties away had the
story.
The Foundation quickly put out a cover story
- the house had probably been destroyed by
a group of grizzly bears, possibly rabid.
They had the local government issue a warning
advising local residents to stay inside and
out of the wilderness until the animals could
be tracked and euthanized.
And that’s exactly what the Foundation did.
Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6, the Village Idiots
an MTF that specializes in taking on anomalous
threats in remote, rural areas and small towns
- were dispatched to track and contain or
terminate whatever had destroyed that mansion.
The creature had left a strong trail of tracks,
scent, and general destruction, and the troopers
followed it north for hours, into another
dense forest – where they discovered the
gigantic, hulking creature while it was asleep
and shot it.
It was huge, with rippling muscles on all
four legs and no fur to speak of – but the
most striking feature was a frighteningly
human face.
The agents resolved to let the researchers
handle the autopsy, and busied themselves
with the other thing in that forest: there
was an old, abandoned arms factory that the
creature seemed to have come from.
The agents descended into the decrepit, abandoned
building, following the creature’s trail
right into the basement.
There, they found a large steel door, and
behind it, the anomaly that would eventually
be called SCP-4049.
It was strange – it seemed to be some kind
of massive, empty room looking up into the
sky, even though they were deep underground.
Not entirely empty - the dirt ground had a
series of concentric rings of gravestones
in it, all facing inward.
The agents retreated once they realized they
had walked into a spatial anomaly and called
for backup.
The Foundation quickly flew in researchers
and a containment team to figure out what
the anomaly was and to ensure no one else
got into the factory while they figured that
out.
The basement of the factory became a sort
of base of operations for the large crew of
research and security personnel assigned to
SCP-4049.
After making sure there were no other of the
monsters, designated SCP-4049-1 instances,
in the nearby forest, the researchers began
to experiment on it.
They determined that the room on the other
side of the hallway was in an extradimensional
space.
Members of D-Class personnel were sent in
with GPS trackers and even though they could
still be heard fine on the radio, the GPS
trackers failed totally.
Obviously, the fact that you could see the
sky from an underground room was anomalous,
but attempts to dig into where the room should’ve
been from the surface also led to nothing
but more dirt.
From inside, the D-Class members were able
to give a detailed report on the room as they
walked around.
It was perfectly circular and pretty large
- about 30 feet across, give or take.
A tall white wall ringed the room’s border
and was perfectly smooth and impossible to
get a grip on enough to climb – cold, hard
marble.
The floor of the room wasn’t marble, though
– it seemed to be regular dirt.
The D-Classes were ordered by researchers
to get samples of what they could, and they
scooped a little dirt into sample bags.
But as soon as the subjects stepped back over
the threshold into the corridor of SCP-4049,
the sample bags they collected spontaneously
combusted, going up in flames.
Any chemical analysis of its composition was,
of course, impossible.
The researchers resolved to get what information
they could out of just looking at SCP-4049
first.
And there was still a lot to look at.
The D-class inspected the rings of gravestones
inside SCP-4049 – there were just two at
the moment, a larger ring containing a smaller
ring.
Inside the smaller ring, there was a circular
empty space a few feet wide.
Most of the graves were unfilled and unmarked
– just a patch of dirt turned over.
But about a dozen of them had a gravestone
at their head, made of that same white marble
substance the walls were made from.
They weren’t fancy – just a simple white
rectangle, stamped with some strange symbols.
The D-class took photos and sent them to the
researchers, who recognized the markings as
a word in Ancient Greek: “hound”.
The researchers were admittedly baffled by
what this could mean for SCP-4049, but decided
to figure out the connection using the evidence
they had: the corpse of the SCP-4049-1 instance.
The researchers placed the huge corpse inside
the factory, creating a secure space to perform
the autopsy.
Then, a team of doctors began cutting into
it with scalpels - or they tried, anyway.
They quickly realized that the skin of the
creature was far too thick to be breached
with scalpels, and resorted to long, sharpened
knives.
They discovered quite a few things about the
instance's anatomy, along with why and how
it was able to do and absorb so much damage.
It was a quadruped, walking on four limbs.
The forward ones seemed to be in the shape
of arms with elbows and wrists, but also had
clawed paws like a dog’s.
The back legs were thick and heavily muscled,
and digitigrade - again, just like a dog,
so they could be used to leap and jump great
distances.
Once they cut away the skin, the researchers
noticed that it was indeed much thicker than
they expected it to be – human skin is only
about 2mm thick, but this was a full centimeter
throughout, as well as incredibly tough and
gamey.
Internally, the structure was all wrong – it
seemed almost human-like, but with a few key
differences to suit the vastly-changed exterior
body.
The spine was much thicker and wider, as well
as being curved to fit the four-legged structure.
There seemed to be redundant organs – the
researchers theorized they were backups, like
the secondary heart they found inside the
creature’s innards.
It could serve as a backup if the main heart
stopped working or was damaged, or it could
work together with the main heart to improve
the instance’s performance during physical
activity.
There didn’t seem to be any kind of reproductive
system – it wasn’t surgically removed,
it just wasn’t there at all, like it had
magically disappeared.
And inside the thing’s head, the skull was
different.
The mouth was much wider and larger, and it
didn’t take long for the researchers to
figure out why.
When rooting around in its mouth, they quickly
discovered it had an extra set of sharp teeth
behind its main set.
All unnerving, slightly disturbing discoveries,
but the most frightening wasn’t something
they found inside the instance.
It was something they noticed immediately
upon containing it – its face was human.
It had been morphed, of course, to fit the
altered skull, but there were two eyes, a
forehead, a nose, lips – it was inarguably
a human face.
When the researchers sent for a DNA test,
they were disturbed but not surprised to discover
what they had already been expecting: the
instance was entirely genetically human.
Not a changed species or close relative – this
creature had once been a regular human being,
like you or I.
The researchers had just sent the DNA sample
off to check if there was a match in the criminal
database when suddenly, the lights went red,
the doors sealed, and the site’s alarms
began to sound
At that moment, the steel door leading to
SCP-4049 flung open, and another SCP-4049-1
instance bounded out into the corridor on
all fours.
It set its beady eyes on three members of
the Mobile Task Force, standing on the far
side of the long corridor.
For a moment, it didn’t do anything – then
it let out a long screech that echoed around
the entire factory.
Its rear legs tensed up, and it began to bound
down the hallway towards them.
All of the security guards opened fire with
their machine guns on the anomaly, trying
to bring it down.
It shrugged off the bullets like they were
raindrops and didn’t so much as slow down.
Meanwhile, the two dozen other security personnel
in the facility were rapidly grabbing their
weapons and armor from their lockers before
rocketing down the stairs to the corridor.
By the time they made it down, it was too
late – the instance was using its claws
and jaws to tear two of the three poor members
of the Task Force to shreds.
It wasn’t eating them - but it was attacking
them with enough anger and malice that there
wasn’t going to be much left when it was
done.
The third member of the task force had fallen
and was backing away from the anomaly in fear.
The remaining members of the Task Force opened
fire, smothering the SCP-4049-1 instance in
a hail of bullets.
The sudden, overwhelming firepower caught
it off-guard, and after a few seconds of sustained
gunfire, it fell to the ground, dead.
Once the Foundation realized the active danger
that SCP-4049 presented, they decided not
to take any chances with containment.
The 50 meter long corridor leading to SCP-4049
from the basement elevator was fortified - an
airlock was installed on the far side, separating
it from the rest of the factory.
Then motion detectors were set every few meters
throughout the hallway, attached to a series
of ‘deterrents’.
If an SCP-4049-1 instance smashed out of the
steel door, it would trip the alarms and activate
everything from a supersonic sound cannon
to sentry guns and a machine gun emplacement.
And if none of those worked, the entire corridor
could be pumped full of nerve gas, guaranteeing
the death of the instance without risking
the lives of any personnel.
This ‘kill corridor’ was to be guarded
by the Applied Task Force Iota-9 to ensure
that no SCP-4049-1 instance would survive
its escape.
But after the corridor was retrofitted, the
Foundation had a bigger problem: where were
these SCP-4049-1 instances coming from to
begin with?
They performed another DNA test on the new
instance – its face was different, so it
seemed logical that it was a different person.
When the results came back, the researchers
were surprised to find that not just one but
both of the samples had DNA matches in the
national database.
Both were men from the tri-state area who
had mysteriously died or disappeared in the
past few months, while at some kind of religious
service.
They were both avid big game hunters, with
an interest in shooting moose, bears, and
elk.
And most important, they had both been the
subject of a fire-related incident – one
had been presumed dead when his house burned
down.
The other had simply vanished, with his car
being found hours later on fire by the side
of the highway.
In both cases, a body was never recovered
- but the authorities did find a strange stone-tipped
arrow driven into the ground nearby.
Over the following months, the Foundation
observed a number of these strange events
happen in Wyoming, Idaho, and Montana, and
like clockwork, every time it happened, a
new headstone appeared over one of the previously-unmarked
graves inside SCP-4049, saying the same Greek
word: “hound”.
On top of all of that, almost every time a
man in the area disappeared under these specific
circumstances and a grave was created, an
SCP-4049-1 instance would appear inside SCP-4049
sometime in the following two months, buried
within the soil circle in the center of the
room.
It would claw its way out of the dirt, smash
open the steel door to SCP-4049, and race
down the hallway trying to kill and destroy
whatever was in front of it until it was gunned
down.
But in one instance, that didn’t happen.
On September 17th of 2015, the Foundation
had gotten into the rhythm of containing SCP-4049,
so they weren’t startled or caught off guard
when an agent with the Highway Patrol reported
finding a flaming truck near a hunting ground
– in the bed was an elk carcass, with a
stone-tipped arrow lodged deep into the meat.
Applied Task Force Iota-9 at the factory began
to prepare for an imminent appearance from
an SCP-4049-1 entity within the following
weeks, and established a round-the-clock guard
in the kill corridor.
But…
it never came.
By December, nothing had happened at all.
The Foundation made the decision – a D-class
would be sent into SCP-4049 with a camera
and radio, in the hopes of manually initiating
the event to occur.
The D-class subject wasn’t given very specific
instructions - just fitted with a body camera,
a two-way radio, and told to listen to all
instructions on his headset.
The researchers ordered him forward until
he reached the other side of the hallway,
where he was to open the steel door leading
to SCP-4049 and enter.
When he entered, everything looked the same
as the Foundation expected it to - the same
gravestones, walls, and dirt.
He moved towards the center of the room, to
the dirt circle, but suddenly stopped, looking
around.
When the researchers asked why, he reported
hearing the sounds of dogs barking for a moment,
before the researchers told him to keep walking.
When he stopped in the center of the room,
he again radioed in, feeling that someone
was there.
The camera didn’t pick anyone up, but he
insisted that there was an odd feeling, just
before his audio stream suddenly cut out.
A burst of static interference drowned everything
else out, and slowly winded down.
The D-class couldn’t be heard anymore – but
a strange female voice was on the line, speaking
to the Foundation.
She mentioned that the Foundation had been
ruining her pets for far too long.
The Foundation demanded the speaker identify
themself, but she just scoffed, indignant
at what she called ‘human arrogance’.
Right after that, all audio feeds were cut
out permanently.
This mysterious woman was designated SCP-4049-2.
Seven seconds after they cut out, the largest
SCP-4049-1 instance ever recorded exited SCP-4049,
standing at almost 11 meters high.
All of the deterrents were activated, but
even then, it still took all of them combined
with machine-gun fire from the Applied Task
Force to bring the creature down.
No remains of the D-class and no traces of
whoever was speaking on the radio were ever
found by the Researchers.
It can be dangerous to stand between someone
and their beloved pets…
Now go watch “SCP-1437 - A Hole To Another
Place” and “SCP-087 - The Stairwell”
for more extradimensional spaces from SCP
Explained!